Aucun de nous connaissait vraiment les autres
On est tous des ratés
Mais bizarrement
On était tous au même endroit au même moment  quand Billy a trouvé ces pièces
Regardez
On brille les gars !
Moi je suis bleu !
Et moi noir !
Eh quoi !
Si c'est vrai !
Non tu déconnes !
Tu te sens bizarre ?
On est fort
Incroyablement fort
La réponse à se qu'il vous arrive se trouve ici
Tous les cinqs
Vous êtes les Power Rangers
Vous venez de dire qu'on était des Power Rangers ?
C'est une blague ou quoi ?
On parle à un mur
Je m'attendais à mieux que vous cinqs
Tu étais où hier soir ?
Avec quatres potes on a trouvés un vaisseaux spatial enfouit sous terre
Je crois que j'ai des super pouvoirs
Cool !
Pisses dans ce bocal !
Les Power Rangers étaient une armée de guerriers
Vous devez devenir ces guerriers
C'est qu'un hologramme comme dans un jeu vidéo
Dans le genre hologramme il cogne fort
C'est pas un jeu vidéo
Vous êtes nés pour ça
Je vais tout détruire
C'est le mal incarné
Du coup on fait comment pour l'arrêter ?
C'est l'heure de la transformation
OOOHHHH !!!
Ça fait un paquet d'or
C'est votre destin
Votre heure est venue